[Musik]
hey ihr lieben heute gibt passend zum
black friday beziehungsweise besser
gesagt zu black wii komplett schwarze
cupcake sondern sei komplett schwarz
dann den schamlosen outfit ich habe
nämlich überlegt dabei es kann ja auch
wirklich sehr auf die frage wie bekomme
ich frosting schwarz wie bekomme ich
teil gespart ist dieses rezept video
einfach perfekt geeignet um auch dieser
frage auf den grund zu gehen denn auch
ich habe versucht for strings mit
lebensmittelfarbe einzufärben und es
wurde dann eher grau als spaß aber ich
habe heute die ultimative lösung für
euch und ich zeige euch jetzt
zuallererst die zutaten für den muffins
die habe ich hier schon bereit wir
benötigen ja gerne auf zimmertemperatur
dann habe ich hier milch und espresso
oder kann auch ausgetauscht werden hier
habe ich zucker mehl war cacau und
backpulver etwas zimmer warme butter
eine prise salz und die geheim zutat
aktivkohle aktivkohle ist unsere geheim
zutat bei diesem rezept es gibt ja
aktivkohle tabletten oder aktivkohle
pulver schon lange das ist ja jetzt
keine neue erscheinung aber in den
letzten jahren bekommt man ja immer mehr
mit dass es eventuell für die
zahnaufhellung gut sein soll oder für
die verdauung
das habe ich alles im internet gelesen
also angaben ohne gewähr
denn mich interessiert nur das thema
backen und ich habe herausgefunden dass
er mit aktivkohle pulver produkte wie zb
for strings oder auch total tiefschwarz
bekommt und dafür müsst ihr das einfach
nur mörsen das mache ich hier' hand dann
bekommt ihr so ein feines pulver
so sieht es dann aus aber wir verwenden
es ja gleich und dann seht ihr den
effekt und ich gebe jetzt zuallererst
für die muffins in meine küchenmaschine
die zimmer warme butter mit dem zucker
und dann schlagen wir das so ungefähr
drei bis vier minuten richtig schön
cremig
[Musik]
die butter zucker massa ist jetzt
richtig schön hell cremig geworden und
da gebe ich jetzt die eier hinzu und für
sie so lange bis sie gerade so verbunden
sind und da könnt ihr gerne auch schon
mal die prise salz mit dazu geben ihre
salz rundet einfach nochmal den
geschmack ab was ich in der zwischenzeit
mache ist folgendes ich fahre schon mal
die trockenen zutaten miteinander
dann verbindet sich nachher alles besser
und dann sieben wir das ganze zusammen
mit milch und espresso auch noch dazu
[Musik]
meine lieben ist es ganz wichtig dass er
die trockenen und die flüssigen zutaten
immer abwechselnd in die masse gibt denn
wenn ihr erst alle trockenen zutaten
rhein gibt habt ihr so eine richtig
feste masse und dann mit den flüssigen
zutaten das aufzulockern
das funktioniert nicht und wir wollen ja
flugfähige muffins daher die reihenfolge
einhalten und ihr habt ja schon gesehen
ich habe einen teil der milch jetzt
durch espresso ersetzt einfach weil ich
finde dass das den schoko geschmack noch
mal so ein bisschen verstärkt falls ihr
das nicht mögt dann einfach die gleiche
menge an milch ersetzen das gebe ich
jetzt hier noch rein und dann kommt nur
noch das aktivkohle pulver und dann seht
ihr schon die farbveränderungen und
fertig ist der tiefschwarze muffin teig
schaut euch das man von der nähe an echt
heftig oder hausgemacht aber wirklich
also so schwarz bekommt man das mit
lebensmittelfarbe kaum hin denn dann
müsste ich vorstellen wieviel
lebensmittelfarbe müsste man da benutzen
und es so schwarz hinzukriegen dann
verändert man ja im endeffekt auch die
konsistenz ist dass wir eben nicht
möchten und jetzt will ich das einmal
gleichmäßig in meine muffin förmchen und
dann werden sie auch schon gebacken bei
180 grad ober und unterhitze im
vorgeheizten backofen für 22 minuten
[Musik]
während unsere muffins aus kühen machen
wir schon mal das leckere frosting und
dafür benötigen wir die folgenden
zutaten
hier habe ich schon mal zimmer warme
butter außerdem bei kakao dass der
starke töte butter zucker und vanille
extrakt etwas schlagsahne ein wenig salz
und aktivkohle wir starten jetzt wird
der zimmer waren brutal die muss jetzt
mindestens acht minuten lang richtig
schön aufgeschlagen werden auf höchster
stufe entwendet jetzt eure
küchenmaschine oder ein handrührgerät
aber bitte beachtet wirklich die minuten
zeit wenn die länge ihres ganze mixed
umso stärker verändert sich die
konsistenz der geschmack und generell
die beschaffenheit und dann sehen wir
uns in mindestens acht minuten wieder
[Musik]
und jetzt schaut wie sich die konsistenz
verändert hat also die butter ist
richtig schön geschmeidig und schon fast
weiß jetzt gebe ich mein wille extrakt
dazu und hier könnt ihr zum beispiel
auch wie der espresso nehmen oder
irgendwelchen sirup leningrad da habt
oder marmelade alles was ihr möchtet
also dass der fantasie überhaupt keine
grenzen gesetzt
ich mache es mit vanilla extra gibt ihn
schon mal dazu und gäbe dann auch schon
mal bei kakao und puderzucker dazu und
das ist ganz wichtig dass ihr dass sie
damit eben keine klümpchen vorhanden
sind
[Musik]
jetzt zeige ich euch die schwarze
buttercreme da habe ich euch zu viel
versprochen und jetzt werden wir die nur
noch mit hilfe einer wunderschönen
spritztour auf unsere muffin spritzen
und darüber könnt ihr dann nach belieben
noch streusel geben und fertig sind die
black cupcakes passt zu black ruhig ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel freude beim
nachmachen
jetzt habt ihr den tipp wie ihr butter
krems wie ihr teil richtig schön schwarz
bekommt und können auf dieses video
immer wieder zurückgreifen und in der
video beschreibung schreibe ich euch
natürlich alle genauen mengenangaben
schaut auf jeden fall rein und schreibt
mir in die kommentare welches cupcake
rezepte als nächstes sehen möchte ja ich
glaube weil es ist ja dass aktivkohle
ist ja das gerücht dass das alte china
ja also kann ich das auch also weiße
zähne durch cupcakes sw revolution in
diesem markt die ja das wär doch mal was
euch jetzt ganz viel freude beim
nachbacken und wir schreiben gerne in
den kommentaren miteinander dann freue
ich mich wenn ihr auch beim nächsten
rezept wieder mit dabei sein
[Musik]